shouldn't you be at school I graduated
high school when I was 15 dad right can
miss a day of college
that's my Jess how he's so quick hey
everybody huge news the flash is
actually doing a version of Johnny quick
in a bonus story that's coming up so if
you remember how they introduced king
shark like they introduced him in this
flash tie-in comic book first then he
came on the TV show we might eventually
see a version of the character on the
show if you're just finding me for the
first time I do flash every week be sure
to subscribe to get everything there'll
be flash ring giveaway stuff at the end
of this - the story itself is actually
somewhere between season 3 in season 4
like its present day because it talks
about the particle accelerator explosion
happening a couple years ago in somebody
in this prologue chapter gets trapped in
the sewers he remembers this urban
legend about a gorilla living in there
so they're talking about all that
gorilla grodd stuff in the sewers from
back during season 1 so they weave in
all kinds of stuff like coast city name
drops and then you find out that there's
somebody who's stealing pieces of humans
to make himself whole again they don't
reveal who the kidnapper is but he says
I only need one thing from you then you
can return to the surface world so he
says great I'll give you anything you
want he starts pulling his wallet out
and he says this will only take a second
and pulls a surgical knife out it's like
he's gonna take a piece from him
but the villains described as having
this necrotic flesh like he has pieces
falling off of him he has worms crawling
on him he has a rat that's inside part
of his skull so it's almost like he's a
ghoul that's trying to leech things from
people so that he can make himself whole
again and it sounds an awful lot like
cicada from the comics but the story
itself is just called the flash Johnny
quick so they might be combining the
Johnny quick character with a version of
cicada who had a special Speed Force
knife that he could use to leech power
from other people or the Speed Force in
order to lengthen his own life the
actual Johnny quick on the TV show would
either have to be a version of Harrison
wells like it has to be a Jay Garrick
thing where he uses his mother's maiden
name like Henry Allen is Barry's father
but Henry Allen of Earth 3 was actually
named Jay Garrick because his mother's
maiden name Barry's grandmother's maiden
name was Garrick turns
jay garrick is not the flash from
earth-2 he's so Derek Derek yeah why my
mom's maiden name where are we
motor car diner in Central City that
would be the way to explain how a
version of Harrison wells could also be
Johnny quick in the arrowverse even
though obviously you know comic book
jesse quick in Johnny quicker completely
separate things he was the one that came
up with the speed formula in the comics
he wasn't struck by a bolt of speed
force lightning the way that Barry was
or some of the other more recent
speedsters but then he had a family his
daughter Jesse Chambers was born when
she was old enough he gave her the
formula and she became Jesse quick and
sort of took the mantle from him the way
the TV shows explained the quick surname
is that it's just an affectation that
Harrison wells gave to his daughter like
all my Jessie always so quick so they
just started calling her that but most
of the time they just referred to her as
Jesse they don't say Jesse quick they've
only released that prologue that I just
talked about the full story won't be out
till April so I'm not expecting them to
bring Johnny quick on to the TV show
this season because they said they're
relatively speedster light but in the
way that the flash TV show borrows a lot
from the comics and they mix and match
things like the trial of the flash is
actually a reverse flash storyline
thinker had nothing to do with it but in
this Johnny quick story it sounds like
there might be a version of Johnny quick
that's evil or acting like cicada or
cicadas another villain for the most
part it's just supposed to be a fun
bonus story built within the world of TV
show flash in the way they've explained
the speedsters is the Jay Garrick came
from another earth so unless they get
really crazy Barry will always be the
first person to have become a speedster
on earth one even though Jay Garrick
solder he came from a different earth so
it doesn't count
so like Johnny quick on the TV show if
he shows up we'll either have to be from
another earth or we'll have to get his
powers tangentially from some subsequent
accident or the original particle
accelerator explosion like the way that
99% of the flash villains got their
powers on the TV show during that first
explosion
although we learned during season 3 this
avatar can use that calcified speed
force to give people powers if there are
alternate versions of them in the
multiverse that had powers during
alternate timelines
[Music]
but that also gets into a little bit of
Hypertime stuff which is a really
complicated way of explaining the
multiverse
so Hypertime is just explaining multiple
different possibilities different
realities as a function of timelines so
the TV show hasn't fully explained this
yet but when Barry created flashpoint he
created an alternate timeline that was
called flashpoint he tried to walk that
back by having reverse-flash go back
kill his parents and then you kind of
noticed that even though a lot of things
went back to being the way they used to
be not everything stayed the same so I
think what they'll reveal eventually is
is that Barry created a third timeline
when he had the reverse-flash fixed that
reverse-flash understood that and that's
why he chuckled a little bit like oh you
know everything's back to normal for me
for the most part but you'll just have
to wait and see what's going on so that
could set the stage for a Hypertime
reveal where they reveal that Barry just
continually creates new realities every
time he changes time like every choice
you make has a certain effect on time
like sometimes it creates little ripples
the ripples go away sometimes it's like
cannonballing into the timeline like
when Barry goes back and saves his
mother I don't want to go too deep into
it because it gets a little complicated
and I don't think the TV show writers
even fully understand the ramifications
of time-travel because I think you know
they're hired each season to write a
story but it really it's the job of the
producers to know how they're gonna
unfold future story like oh this is what
we want to do next season so because one
of the episode titles is supposed to be
flash time it sounds like they're
teasing some Hypertime reveal where they
just have a slightly different way of
contextualizing the choices that Barry
makes for the most part Barry's fight
this season's against the thinker that's
more a fight of the mind like a grand
chess game that they're playing with
each other we still don't know what the
thinker's plan is for enlightening the
human race likes avatar wanted to
scatter himself across all of time zoom
wanted to destroy the entire multiverse
so there's just like some big huge plan
that we won't find out about to the last
couple of episodes probably but we'll
get some clues in the next couple of
episodes so just let me know what do you
think about the idea of them doing
Johnny quick bonus stories how do you
want them to incorporate those other
older speedsters from the comics like we
still have max mercury he's another
a classic speedster we have a version of
mercury labs but that's as close as
we've gotten and if that wasn't enough
we just found out that Matt Letcher who
plays the original version of eobard
thawne
was just cast on a season of narcos so
they bring reverse-flash back before the
end of this year then it'll have to be
either the Tom Cavanagh version of the
reverse-flash or like he said during the
crossover I wonder which face I'll be
wearing next they could always roll out
a version of him who has stolen someone
else's face but that would feel kind of
weird I think part of the reason for
that reverse flash line is because they
didn't know whether or not Matt lecher
would be cast on another show and they
were just hedging their bets like maybe
we'll lose this actor for the next year
or so because he'll be busy on another
show so we need to give ourselves some
wiggle room if we want to use the
character later and we need to recast so
it'll make sense so if you saw the news
recently they just announced that
they're working on a black widow movie
whether or not that actually gets made
remains to be seen but I'll do a
reaction video for that we also got some
more pictures from Avengers 4 that
implies some really crazy time-travel
stuff so just look out for that
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Jack mitchellson
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there was another
round on this video I'll just announce a
winner the next time I post DC click
here for a brand new flash and click
here for my brand new Black Panther
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight